mais ce que je peux voir l'abattre s'il
vous plaît merci de les recycler très
simple j'ai à vous dire le jeu c'est
très simple vous allez devoir tourner
comme ceci ohlala qu'on fait
vous faites jolie vous allez faire allez
on va faire dix tours vous devez tirer
celui qui le met qualifié celui qui ne
met pas rentrer chez lui il passe sur le
plateau d'accord allez on va commencer
par ben basât matin au départ qui avait
fait trois tours mais toi tout dans la
tête à gagner la tête sans comment
éliminer bassamat il pas les spectres
plateau allées du palais sur le plateau
combattit autant on t'expliquera
attention bien là sur le truc allez
c'est pas eux et sa tournée sata iii et
paris qui dévoila
attention attention maxime daigneault
encore j'étais à ma coulée alors place
au temple un humaniste a perdu sans
déconner gilles j'en peux plus ce sous
type sur la tête de ma mère
ap aussi amie isabelle tu veux le faire
maintenant j'ai peur qu'on va la voir
faire agathe tu regardes et tu peux mais
c'est là que le rester là
ça fait cinq ans fait sa com
on avait fait un énorme effort n'est pas
là rien compris c'est la belle avait dit
pendant deux heures c'est fini oh oui oh
là là les meufs ça ça va ma rien
je réponds à l'évasion où vas tu veux
mais un ballon bien bien bien le front
le premier est la malade aurait donc pas
trop pas trop mal et vallini ce matin
dans le balo et là pas de ballon à côté
avant mathieu mais concède truc c'est ça
les gars du quotidien
je regrette ouais merci c'était plus
fort que tout donne ma gueule connard
allez merci avec lydiane ses obligés de
tourner dans certains cas les attentions
avec les faits alors qu'on allait en
fait que deux tours tu fais que deux
tours on lui doit bien non ça marche
bien avec kevin calais c'est bon quand
on entend
mais pour l'instant le gardien se balade
pour l'instant tout le monde était
limité la banque a marqué match de suite
c'est mérité alors je vais dire gilles
est un très très bon joueur de foot ne
restait au maine il joue très très très
bien géré attention à faire trois tonnes
et pas 3 tonnes on va papa j'essaie de
tourner dès à présent pas 3 tonnes que
je conteste les cinq femmes effet pas
annoncé m a dit allez je vous
normalement à l'attention c'est bon
attention il va nous tirer d'assaut
alors que ces mamies qui valent marque
pas mais je te jure et les villages il
est limité
attention si c'est possible
allez géraldine moi je vais bien être
éliminé 1 1 alors allez c'est parti on y
va aller jouer mais regardez là mais ça
si les grandes eaux là déjà ça tourne en
aller
c'est pas moi il était pas allé là allez
jean luc jean luc mathieu tu es éliminé
tu sors la 3è sort du cadre hors du
cadre sont longtemps personne n'a de
cadeaux on aimer la personne notre
cadeau
après tu gères miens bien aujourd'hui
qu'il faut admettre fait pas l'oral et
mamie 10 à batterie fois serait pas
admissible à les attentions
pour l'instant je continue si l'ofj des
trois buts face aux nets a pas tourné
toi déjà je veux dire déjà terres déjà
en difficulté pas mal et cela vas y si
je le marque
on doit tous magna cadeaux demain je
suis pas sûr que ce soit votre cliff
sicile à aller à tenir si jean-luc tant
d'amour est vraiment cinq tours c'est un
vrai cadeau
ap